[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
there was a video that was circulating
that was sent to me and i avoided
watching it
today i came to visit brothers
and we was talking about this and it
came to my attention and i'm going to
try to watch it i haven't seen it before
um and we want to elaborate on it
because i think there's
big lessons for us to learn from that
inshallah so here it goes
okay guys so i don't know what was being
said but um
i don't know it's sometimes you get lost
for words with
yeah there's no excuses honey it's
you know it reminds me of a narration
from abdullah bin umar
and he saw and a yemeni man carrying his
mother on his
shoulders doing tawaf and
he was doing tawaf and as he was doing
that he was repeating a chance he was
saying you know i am my mother's
humble camel well i'm like my mom's
donkey like he was belittling himself
and he came to abdullah bin umar and he
said did i repeat back my mom because
i've
carried her all this time except you're
doing tawa have i repaid her back for
what she's done for me
he said you didn't pay her back for one
off she said when she was giving birth
to you
you did not repay her back for one of
you she gave
she did when she was giving birth to you
now to see this
vile man to hit his mom
with that force and rage well lie to me
it's yani
this man i personally believe you and
these kind of people brother sisters
well
i believe their hands should be broken
and i'll be honest with you
and you might say it's harsh well i
don't think it's harsh at all the one
who's looked after you and brought you
to this age for you to
no matter what while like if your mom is
coming to you with a sword
you know what you need to do you need to
run she's coming to you with a gun you
need to hide
to justify and people do this while
you'll be shocked i hear a stories
people
beating their own mothers hitting their
own mothers swearing out their own
mothers calling police
on their own mothers brothers and
sisters while he don't ever expect
any barakah in your life you're looking
be it marriage be it business be
whatever if you see that there is
problems always arising nothing's going
right
question certain things your
relationship with others if you can't
even
wrong a cat what about the one who
has bad you for nine months and
sometimes don't get it twisted with my
mom sometimes yes
i upset my mom how sometimes she wants
something i'm like mom this
let's do this it's better and then i
realize i had a realization two days ago
and i said to myself you know what
ali you're giving a recommendation but
maybe your mom doesn't want that
recommendation
maybe what she wants and i'll give you
the example if my mom says to me
go and get milk and i say mom she says
go get milk from
this shop let's suppose yeah okay
sainsbury's or tesco whatever you want
to call it yeah
and i got mom but they sell the same
milk here brother if your mom saying go
tesco go tesco if your mom is or parents
or dad is telling you to do something do
it
oh no i no no one like i'm telling you
i'm guilty sometimes my dad asked me for
certain things
and i'm like okay i'll do it anyone says
oh you always say you do it you don't do
it one night it's embarrassing
if this is embarrassing if this we
should question ourselves
and ask ourselves subhanallah what about
the one who raises his hand to be
to his mother while he don't i'm telling
you
do not ever think you're going to smell
the fragrance of jannah
if you are beating your own mom hitting
your own mom insulting your own mom
swearing at your own mom while you know
what is the biggest biggest worst thing
that your mom reaches our old age and
you put in a care home and you're dead
and this is happening in this very
moment in this capitalistic
um times that we live in oh a nuisance i
can't look after us too much
wife doesn't want it and you take them
and put them in care homes
lonely you don't go to visit them
how would you answer allah on the day of
judgement this video shows to you an
extreme scenario brothers and sisters we
need to work on
smaller smaller things because our
parents and you're going to be a parent
you know if you're a mom a dad that's
what mama always says to me
say to me you will know your mom would
say to me the day you have your own
child you say to me mom you haven't
loved me enough
that's what mum would say to me they
will say once you have your own child
you say you know what mom
you haven't loved me enough because you
would understand the loved one has
towards their child
brothers and sisters imagine you
bringing a child to this age and he's
like this anyways
this person doing this brothers and
sisters cherish your parents because
i know people whose parents have died
they will give the entire globe and
world to have them here for a split
second subhanallah we ask allah to deal
with this guy
guide him inshallah i'm not going to say
much
and inshallah we learn a lesson from his
brother and sisters cherish your mom
wallahi if you're watching this video
go and kiss your mom's feet obey your
parents well like go get them flower
whatever it may be
best while and one thing that i'll tell
you do not leave the house without your
mom's blessings
if i ever upset my mom i say mom wallahi
well i'm not trying to sound humble or
lie i fear i go and something happens to
me i fear
because i've upset you mom please
forgive me i was wrong i was i was wrong
forgive me you have to honor and one
thing israel brown sisters kiss the
forehead of your parents
your mom or your dad honor them when
they come we've done this from
when your dad comes you get up from him
do not ever ever call him by his name
when he's walking do not walk in front
of him when he's talking don't
ever subhanallah brothers and sisters
obey your parents allah says in the
quran after i command you to worship me
you obey your parents wallahi this is
what we should do inshallah
and for those people and i'll finish on
this note subhanallah some people
they want a certain game or they want to
play something their parents they get
off it
they insult their parents young kids who
are playing games and stuff like this
fear allah while that very game that
you're so addicted to
a day would come you would die and give
all those games in return for your
mother
to be there cherish your parents before
it's too late because once they're gone
no regrets going to bring them back
assalamu alaikum what happened
to